Every year through
the annual budget process
Yale thoroughly reviews
its financial resources
and the strategic goals
that serve to advance
the university's mission.
We carefully consider new
and continuing opportunities
for supporting students, faculty
and staff
across the university
and for partnering with our home
city of New Haven.
The purpose of this video
is to explain where funding for
the budget comes from,
how it's allocated,
and how we make those decisions.
[upbeat music]
(Scott)
The university budget falls
into two basic categories.
First is the operating budget,
which is the ongoing costs
of what it takes
to run a university
on a day to day basis
throughout the year.
The other is the capital budget
and the capital budget
is what it takes to be able
to build new buildings
or renovate existing buildings
for their use.
One key to the budget
is that this is incredibly
collaborative.
It involves input from
so many different places
in the university,
all of whom are working together
to try to develop a budget
by late spring
that can be approved
by the corporation
and then move forward to define
spending in the coming year.
This begins
with a set of parameters
that are given
to each budgetary unit
that define things like what
we anticipate inflation
will be, what we anticipate
the endowment return will be.
Those are then brought back
to what's called
the Budget Advisory Group.
The Budget Advisory Group
is comprised of the provost,
those in the Provost Office,
senior administrative leadership
in the Department
of Finance and Operations,
as well as several faculty
that provide perspective
and input to understand
both the financial side
as well as the academic side
of all these budget requests.
We work to create a budget
which reflects
our current needs,
but also reflects the need to be
financially responsible
into future generations.
External revenue
for the operating budget
comes from a variety of sources.
For the past year, 2022,
which runs from July 1st 2021
until June 30th 2022.
That revenue contributes just
over $4.7 billion to the budget.
It might be surprising to
see that tuition, room and board
comprise a relatively small
slice of this overall revenue.
It's just $450 million or about
10% of the university budget.
That's the net amount
after 50% of the gross tuition
room and board is returned
in the form of financial aid.
The two biggest
sources of income
are spending from the endowment,
which contributes about
1.6 billion or 33%
and medical services income,
which is 1.4 billion
or 29% of the total budget.
The third largest
contributor of revenue is grants
and contracts
at $921 million or 19%
of the total budget.
[thoughtful music]
Yale's annual operating budget
is a combination
of all the sources of revenue
we anticipate
for the coming year
as well as all of the expenses
or spending we anticipate
for the coming year.
Every year the anticipated
expenses of the annual budget
are typically close to the
amount of anticipated revenue.
For the fiscal year 2022,
expected expenses
net of internal revenue
are about $4.6 billion.
Yale seeks to improve the world
by creating knowledge
and sharing that knowledge,
and that's a mission that's
carried out by and for people.
So it makes sense
that the biggest category
of expenses at Yale
are the salaries and benefits
for the people who work here.
The nearly 5000 faculty
and about 10,000 staff.
In the fiscal year 2022 budget,
salaries and benefits total
$2.9 billion or
nearly two thirds
of the university's budget.
Included in the $2.9
billion is about
$700 million in employee
benefit costs.
Most of which over 90% are
health and retirement related.
Non-salary expenses account
for another $1.5 billion
of the budget.
These include a wide range
of costs, including utilities,
medical supplies and services,
lab supplies and equipment,
consulting and professional
services, acquisitions of books,
periodicals and artworks,
and many other costs.
You can find more details
on these expenses
and much more
about the operating budget
in the University Budget book,
which is available
to all faculty,
staff and students
on the Provost's website.
The Yale budget process
allows each school and unit to
bring forward
their annual budget
in line with their strategic
initiatives that they've
put forth in a long range plan
for approval.
This is an opportunity for those
that get provostial funds
to ask for funding for ideas
that they have
put forward in line
with the mission of their school
or in mission of the university.
Once the officers, deans
and unit leaders,
along with their lead
administrators,
put together their proposals,
we meet with the Budget
Advisory Group
during the months of March
and April.
Everyone comes forward
and does a presentation.
Decisions
are made really based on
the operational
needs of the unit
and we also look
at the president and provost
strategic initiatives
for the next five to ten years.
And we also look at
what ideas will
have the strongest outcomes
on the university and advance
the mission of the university.
We summarize the entire budget
for the provost
who then presents it
to the president,
who then presents it in
the June Corporation meeting
to the trustees of Yale
University for approval.
Once we gain approval,
we communicate
all that to the lead
administrators, the deans
and officers for the new year,
and that happens in June
and we turn over the
new year July 1st.
[inspiring music]
Obviously the budget is
everything
that is the university,
and so it supports everything
that is in the university:
all the people, all the places,
all the collections,
all the operations are supported
by this budget.
It involves every aspect of what
the university does:
from the clinical practice
to what collections are found
in the libraries, to what
the salaries are for faculty
and staff, what financial aid
we provide to students.
The most important thing
the university does is to
recruit
the next generation of scholars
as we create
the community of scholars
that is Yale University.
The budget is the key tool
that we utilize for that
recruitment as we further
diversify our faculty
and as we develop
the emerging fields
that are happening across
different disciplines,
it's a moment to reimagine
what the fields are,
to reimagine
what the university looks like,
what the composition
of the university is,
and then to make these
investments in people
and in the spaces
that are needed for those people
to thrive.
The generosity of our donors
over multiple decades
makes it possible for us
to admit students without regard
to their need, without regard
to their financial circumstance,
which is fundamentally
an opportunity
to have the most diverse
student body possible
where we can recruit students
to campus from all backgrounds
independent of what
their financial resources
reflect
that we can bring them
from really all over the world.
We can create the most diverse
student body utilizing the power
of the endowment
to be able to cover the costs
of an education at Yale.
The university's budget
has to be part of building
an inclusive workplace.
(Deborah)
When we start to think
about the composition
of the organization,
we think about faculty,
we think about students,
we certainly think
about the 11,000
plus staff
that are part of the community.
But I also think the word
community is what's
most important to me.
And so the university's budget
allows us to build community
through a variety
of different ways
For staff diversity
it helps us to attract talent.
The university's budget includes
a large commitment
to the City of New Haven.
I believe our commitment
is approximately $135 million
over a six year period.
And as a result of that,
I think it makes us the largest
university
commitment to its host city.
And for me
that's quite exciting
given that I'm a resident and
native of the city of New Haven.
The budget process is dynamic.
It reflects the revenue that's
coming into the university.
Sometimes the endowment goes up
and sometimes it goes down
and we have to make
adjustments accordingly.
And so through the generosity
of donors over
multiple years, over centuries,
that endowment
has grown to the point
where it provides
a substantial portion
of our budgetary support
that makes it possible
for us to invest in the future,
for us to carry out our mission,
for us to support our students
and our faculty and our staff,
to create
a community of scholars
that is seeking the future
of academic disciplines
and thriving
in all of its missions.